[Musique]
avis aux demandeurs d'emploi la SPL Eden
recrute dans le cadre de ses activités
liées à la lutte anti vectorielle la
société qui exerce aussi des missions de
préservation de la biodiversité et des
espaces naturels pour le compte du
département recherche des hommes et
femmes de pieds un métier méconnu qui
consiste à sécuriser et seconder les
grimpeurs et la guerre lors de
l'entretien des cours et des jardins
dans le but de pourvoir ces postes mais
aussi de faire connaître cette
profession la SPL Eden a prévu deux jobs
dating en commençant par ce mercredi 5
avril à l'Espace redle à Saint-Denis on
va recruter aujourd'hui ce qu'on appelle
des hommes et femmes de pied il s'agit
de recruter 9 personnes qui vont ensuite
être embauchés au sein de la SPA Lidl la
particularité aujourd'hui c'est qu'on
propose un parcours en plat compétences
qu'on qualifie chaque excellence
c'est-à-dire que les gens vont pouvoir
bénéficier en amont même de leur entrée
en la compétence chez nous d'une
formation en partenariat avec le CFPPA
terraforma et financé par le Pôle emploi
une formation de 105 heures qui vont
pouvoir qui va pouvoir leur donner une
qualification de grimpeurs sauveteur
dans l'arbre on va avoir une période
d'observation pour voir comment il
s'adapte à notre objectif et puis si les
choses sont concluantes pour pour ces
personnes là on va même pouvoir les
amener vers des fonctions de chaque
équipe suppléant donc vraiment avoir un
parcours organisé en amont pendant avec
un accompagnement socio-professionnel
dédié par les accompagnatrices de la de
la SPA Eden des conditions d'embauche
attractives mais surtout un vrai
parcours de réinsertion professionnelle
vers un poste à responsabilité cette
formation donc elle va durer 105 heures
elle commencera donc le 17 avril et
finira le 12 mai les gens donc seront
indemnisés par Pôle Emploi donc tous les
mois et ils auront aussi l'indemnité de
frais kilométrique et des frais de repas
il y aura aussi une possibilité
d'hébergement donc en partenariat avec
l'organisme de formation et après à
l'issue de cette formation donc il
finira mimer les gens sont recrutés en
parcours en plein compétences à compter
du 1er juin
2023 donc pour une durée de 11 mois et
si ces personnes donnent satisfaction
donc on sera pas sur un Pecq lambda de
24 heures ou 24 heures dans le cadre du
plan de relance mais sur des pecs donc
de 30 ou 35 heures et ces gens seront
amenés à être donc futur chef adjoint
d'équipe donc à l'aspel était après
présentation de la formation qualifiante
et du contrat PEC excellence les
recruteurs ont enchaîné les entretiens
face à eux des candidats sérieux et
motivés
[Musique]
et
comme moi j'ai déjà de l'espérance déjà
dedans donc mon but à moi c'était déjà
d'évoluer d'être chef d'équipe quoi fait
parce que comme j'étais l'espérance déjà
en train d'équipe et responsable de
secteur en entretien dans différents
secteur professionnel donc de ma
présence ici
à l'entretien d'aujourd'hui en fait la
SPL Eden c'était donner le défi
d'attirer er les profils féminins sur un
métier dit d'homme défi relevé avec brio
je suis venue pour aller entretien pour
être
femme de pied dans l'espace vert et
aussi pour voir au-delà de ce que je
peux donner comme expérience il faut
être sportif par rapport
courir un peu à gauche à droite
rapport les outils il est un peu lourds
et physiquement il faut on a
le corpulence comme une femme peut le
faire il faut jamais sous-estimer une
femme une matinée de Job Dating réussie
à Saint-Denis qui se poursuit le jeudi 6
avril cette fois-ci dans le sud à
Saint-Pierre
[Musique]